vous avez toujours rêvé d'être un
personnage de manga ou d'animer cela est
maintenant possible
lyon tous vos de squeeze aujourd'hui on
se trouve sur facebook à une nouvelle
version de jeu qui est sorti avec des
avatars 2d de type manga est ce que
c'est pas formidable ce qui se passe
1 la technologie parcours il peut pas
être méchant c'est dire que cet homme
est décédé gentil toute sa vie voyez
aude et qui sont dehors quand il est en
colère
je vais te défoncer
voilà tiers quand je fais ça lui est
totalement normal miam miam nam nam nam
nam yao il estime qu il a un petit
charisme ou pas mais pourquoi ils sont
autant blasé c'est ma morphologie qui
leur plaît pas il a gardé les yeux
normaux quand je faisais quoi salut je
suis un beau gosse avec une cravate je
suis sûrement connu dans les mangas ou
les animés mais squeeze ne me connaît
pas ce gros con ah ouais je pense que
c'est des personnages connus d'animaux
de manga mais que je connais pas
forcément aux communicants rail ont
appelé samedi à calais c'est que le
renard pedobear alerte
il est tellement mignon squeeze arrête
[ __ ] être aux canaux savent séduire à
toi les blasés je suis un truc millions
et les blasés en vrai salut je m'appelle
et me lisent vient tout droit de naruto
cfoa temps on dit rires aux dna sur deux
mais jy comment il s'appelle déjà
ils attaquent s'appelle salut moi c'est
une attaque je suis amoureux naruto
depuis maintenant longtemps je rêve
secrètement de lui toutes les nuits je
suis la fille qui rêvait de tous les
admirateurs de manga soit padeg
l'acolyte de saitama salue ces géniaux
sefyu guaino juge pas comme on dit on
s'en fout et je suis un pur obg
voilà c'est mon maître qui est chaud me
mets la branlée et demain je peux
ressentir ton pouvoir a dans ses yeux un
problème tu kiffes mon visage de profil
ou par des clubs les jeux ça pue qui
grossit regarder le problème 1 où je
suis juste débile à terssac mais [ __ ]
de dieu parole des grévistes c'est pas
encore ça
ils peuvent soit être normaux soit une
blasé souhaite normaux voire salut toi
ça te dirait qu autour d'un petit en
taille ensemble à paul pas gagner plus
tout est un problème on dirait qu'elle
est encore 1 au stade croquis celle là à
t pas encore dans l'animé c'est ça qui
est en train d'être créée ok j'avais pas
d'exception du visage toi ah ouais tu es
vraiment fait avoir trop de botox ou le
botox madame assez dommage que les
chevaux ils bougent pas plus que m
est ce qu'on peut ah non ça marche pas
hatsune miku sacré
elle a bien changé l eau moi c'est chou
il bouge de manière hyper naturel en
plus regardées n'ont débouché bravé un
truc bordel on dirait que tu es morte la
hâte sous des [ __ ] n'avons pas que
quelque 40 dans cette pièce à ce moment
là qui va du petit ou en stylo d'orly
alors moi j'ai quatre bras à sibra pas
bon je racontais c'est affreux parce
qu'en fait avec l'effet 2d on dirait que
même les méchants sont gentils pourtant
elle a tout de dégueulasse est là j'ai
moyen d'un avc avant la fin de ce
tournage
oh on est un [ __ ] de poney amputé il
marche bien en plus lui par des
psychopathes poney autun poney millions
poney atteint d'une grave maladie
poney styrène poli bonne épouse
elle était tellement naze laval [ __ ]
le conte merci mon pote
voilà tu es mon salami et bien lui aussi
[ __ ] mais c'est ouf quoi qu'on puisse
vraiment devenir le personnage en 2d de
dettes des dessins rien à orienter on a
envie de prendre ces petites boules de
poils à des joutes émis à tort trop cute
là alors là on a un truc trop mignon je
suis super mignon et j'ai même pris du
trm fo cabral a way ma vie ce soit en
regardez ces mouvements de sourcils à
aller suivant au toujours plus mignon ou
encore mochis à la phase encore croquis
comme l'autre or il est trop chou
oh mon dieu saitama je suis webmaster
père [ __ ] décidément ils nous quittent
plus lui oh là là [ __ ] étaient ils
étaient hostiles et saitama tout blasé
en plus il peut devenir tellement bg
quand il s'énerve atteint c'est
tellement génial c'est génial c'est la
meilleure nation du monde messieurs
dames et l'heure de remettre le prix de
la mignonne
car c'est une roulette pour poils de
chats y alors petit peu mais c'est beau
mais d'ici là j'espère passer d'une
surface rixe sur le dlc où on peut
maintenant incarner des personnages
d'animer et de mangas c'est juste génial
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça vous a
plu attend celui qui vous lie en plus
d'être obligé la visite à fort sur un
peu quand même non non c'est faux
tiens prends ton prix et tais toi donc
pas savoir garder ou retrouver dans une
prochaine vidéo on finit sur un coup de
poing intel saitama aurait fait